[Music]
today's question comes from tom in
illinois and this may be my favorite
blinds.com question of all time i listen
to the show every day he says i
appreciate how you advise people about
money but i'd like to ask dave given
your net worth dave why are you still
working
it makes the assumption that i was
working for money
that's right that's true and i quit
working for money a long time ago i make
money and i use it for keeping score
because i want to know if i won the game
but um am i actually serving because if
you serve people they'll give you
certificates of appreciation with
president's faces on them my friend
rabbi lapin says that and so
i like keeping score but uh no i don't
you're right i'm not working because of
my net worth i'm not working because of
that working because of the impact what
you said earlier yeah the um
i mean honestly
let's just let's just be let's just be
real okay couple guys i like this okay
you ready yeah
who wouldn't like a job
who for three hours every day people
call and ask your opinion about
something that's a very good point
where else would you get so true you'll
get that at home
no where else do you get this yeah it's
a it's a freaking ego stroke but i mean
you speak in front of thousands and
thousands of people you know millions
here on the air yeah and you know people
actually ask my opinion and some of them
care about it the thing your name is all
over the building that can't be bad
walking in every day yeah it's that
don't do it that don't do it
that gets boring fast but yeah i mean
really it's a great job well it is and
you know you talk about this all the
time i mean when we look at the problems
in our culture
um you know i never i never you know
i've never run into anybody in 30 years
in a restaurant that came up to me and
goes uh you know ramsay you got me out
of debt my life sucks i hate you right
that has never been said it doesn't
happen i've had people mad at me about
other things like you don't need to talk
so much about politics you're mean on
the radio i hear i hear that kind of
stuff yeah but nobody ever said you know
you got me out of debt and i hate you
it's true is it just never got that in
30 years so
um no it's fun it's good everybody loves
to give their opinion that's why that
whole uh remember jay leno our friend
you know they used to go on social media
ask people their opinion they'll tell
you anything yeah yeah social media is a
wreck for that very reason oh yeah gives
a bunch of people an opinion that
shouldn't have one you know it's just
crazy so um
that's why you do it
i like stirring up a ruckus yes all
right